un video al giorno vi fa ridere Questa
cosa visto che non faccio un video al
giorno da una vita e adesso escono eh di
quasi un'ora quindi vabbè ormai zoncos
non gli chiedi che cosa avete Ma si può
entrare nei posti tutti io io non ci
posso credere Ragazzi io Fatico a
credere questa cosa Accio ho visto che
c'è una pagina bastardaccio chi t'è
muort Dov'è passo Ecco l'ho mancata
porca dove ero ragazzi c'ho la pagina
che volava non sono pazzo Togliti
Comunque ragazzi eh Hogwarts Legacy Eh
inoguase ragazzi puoi fare tutto a
quanto pare puoi fare qualsiasi domanda
Mi scusi va bene va bene va bene va bene
bellissimo interagiscono anche quando
fai qualcosa Comunque
ce l'ho fatta
Allora ragazzi Eravamo rimasti a parte
il cazzeggio totale che che sto tirando
fuori eravamo rimasti che devo prendere
la bacchetta da olivanger olivander che
ovviamente è il bacchetta Taro del di
Harry Potter
qua però non si parla di olivander ma
dovrebbe
essere la famiglia o arrivare quindi non
è più lui ma qualche antenato suo
vediamo
jer Bold
Che fico
Che figata Che figata Che figata
bellissima ruba tutto ruba provare Scusa
Salve
poi ragazzi qualcosa Un attimo solo
Un momento eh Penso sia il padre o il
nonno di olivander Buongiorno Sto
cercando una bacchetta Sì grazie
Ma di certo avrei già sentito parlare
degli Oliver e migliori produttori di
bacchette adesso È un piacere conoscerti
davvero su Vieni con me troviamo la
bacchetta Ma allora ragazzi Io so una
cosa tu potevi fare anche il test su
Potter Morra Pa A quanto pare ti dà te
la segnava già
solo che non l'ho fatto quindi vabbè mi
conosci
nucleo potente 10 pollici adesso come
minimo l'agito e si scassa tutto pure
qui non so se hanno fatto il Cliché lo
stesso di Harry Potter Non è detto eh
Ma poi le bacchette si possono cambiare
durante il gioco
Che strano
Prova ancora su brandiscila bene
No no assolutamente no Beh direi che non
ci siamo perfetto
mi dai quella di Sambuco lo so Non
preoccuparti
ha risposto direttamente no se non c'è
anche quella di Sambuca adesso Ragazzi
mi farà fare un test 100% per Per far sì
che io Scelga la bacchetta tu potresti
[Musica]
Ecco lo sapevo mi faceva fare il test
100%. Allora
Ah la faccio io Ah ok questa questo è il
riepilogo Vabbè allora stile bacchetta
la faccio io no Vabbè ragazzi scusate è
pieno No è bellissimo Scusatemi raga è
importante questo Eh devo farla devo
scegliere bene Scusatemi raga ovviamente
raga corda di cuore di Drago cioè tra
tutte vi direi che assenza sono molto
potenti e grazie Allora ho scelto legno
Alloro questo perché a loro significa
Lorenzo Cioè Lorenzo significa a loro
non lo sapete sta roba Beh corda di
quelli drago inflessibile 12 pollici e
3/4 secondo me è la mia bacchetta nera
perché io mi vesto sempre tempo un
outfit molto bella secondo me sono il
mago più potente del mondo con questa
altro che Voldemort è Grindelwald e
tutti sci stronzi Eccola qua
straordina Thank you e me la sono fatta
io grazie
nostro futuro grazie Oliver
bellissimo me la sono fatta io raga
fantastico
[Musica]
Sì ma quanto costa 800 mila euro ok Ho
percepito una specie di scarica di
energia un buon abbinamento tra voi c'è
una connessione potente
Quanto costa una barche a parte gli
scherzi non vedo l'ora di provarla
un nucleo di corda del cuore di Drago è
in grado di produrre magie strabilianti
è il legame tra voi due diventerà sempre
più forte non sorprenderti se la tua
nuova bacchetta sembrerà percepire le
tue intenzioni in particolare nei
momenti di bisogno mi sembra fantastico
signor olivander ti lascerò le tue cose
allora torna pure pochissimo ormai
dovesse servirti qualcosa veramente figo
bene La cosa divertente è che non l'ho
pagata c'è la l'ha pagata il gioco io
non l'ho pagata per niente forziere
posso rubiamo da olivander i soldi che
gli ho appena dato va benissimo
signor rivanunder non se n'è accorto ma
quindi adesso c'ho familiare e Sì c'ho
la mia bacchetta Bellissima quindi io
non posso cambiare bacchetta Ma non la
cambierei comunque perché è troppo [__]
la mia quindi non avrebbe senso adesso
sono molto geloso della mia bacchetta
e quindi Let's go vediamo se riusciamo
andare a fare altre missioni perché vedo
che qua mi dice di parlare con
[Musica]
visita la rapa magica pozioni di jpyn e
Tommy e pergamene Ma zonco che cos'è
Voglio le cose che vendono qua Ah sembra
il negozio di prese George questo Cos'è
dalle cose da vendere qua no chiedo per
un amico posso comprare questo
Ah è uno spara palloncini Bello bello si
può comprare qualche no chiedo perché è
talmente figo sto posto che secondo me
si può comprare qualcosa di figo tipo
qualcosa da sparare in giro Salve ma c'è
una cassa non so quanto è grosso sto
bastone enorme
ok Questo no non c'è una non c'è una
cassa quindi non posso non posso andare
a comprare Ah si esce anche di sopra Ah
bello Vabbè volevo comprare delle cose
la zonco ma non c'è chi me le vende
allora e rubiamo o se no Ragazzi
dove vado ma non si aprono tutte le
porte sarebbe follia Ah ok cioè Siamo
veramente incredibile va bene tutto
Allora
visita tu mi pergamene e dove cacchio
sono qua Stiamo uscendo a meno che non
ci no non stiamo uscendo
Ok
C'è un gatto ad accarezzare va bene
a questi scassina con l'onore Va bene
Allora ragazzi la devo imparare
Scusatemi ma
qua ci posso entrare Tra l'altro va bene
Salve Buongiorno siete un cazzo qua
dentro problemi No volevo fare L'altro
tipo Lumos
si vede ancora meno però mi scusi mica
sa dove sono Tommy e pergamene Vabbè fa
niente questa vende i gatti Secondo te
No basta
ogni tanto non so dove che ne so dimmi
nella mappa dove sono le cose cacchio ne
so Eh andiamo se mi butto nel fiume
muoio
non so se scoprirla o meno sta roba
vabbè c'è il ponte Sticazzi perché
volevo attraversare non sapevo come mai
nel dubbio non moriamo non Ah no ma si
può notare Ah già ma si può notare che
pirla potevi provare che è successo
che cazzo è successo niente
[Musica]
Chi è che è il monache sbatte la porta
lì Fammi vedere no perché è un forziere
[__] Ma che è
hai un forziere che si apre
solo se non c'è nessuno vicino Ok allora
forse mi devo avvicinare piano no perché
se ne accorge
quindi devo andare l'invisibile
Scommetti Vabbè allora c'è una porzione
di invisibilità devo tornare qua con la
pozione così almeno mi avvicino e riesco
ad aprirlo vediamo se si può notare
Penso di sì
Madonna Bellissima sta roba Sì la sapevo
eh Solo che non non avevo ancora provato
Vabbè vamos c'è questo forse io rubo le
cose berretto ho trovato un berretto Ci
mancava solo questo già faccio schifo e
faccio ridere Ci manca solo il berretto
vediamo
accessori per la testa questo è un
berretto ed è un berretto normale quindi
non Mamma mia faccio vomitare
mi tolgo me lo tolgo
modifica aspetto togli sta roba perché è
veramente ridicolo
ciò non è male Però vabbè cioè lo posso
equipaggiare però non non
facendolo vedere questa cosa è possibile
allora
praticamente no allora pergamene Tommy e
pergamene Specialist bookshop
era letteralmente all'entrata di orzsmi
Salve
ad esempio
esatto
Ma come
è successo Mi scusi non volevo e non lo
sapevo e mettere un cazzo di ascensore
invece ti fa Vabbè va bene grazie Ho
fatto una non lo sapevo
Bellissimo E quindi cosa c'è c'è
forziere Cioè non hanno messo il
forziere nascosto nella stanza di sotto
l'hanno messo di sopra per aprirlo e
devi fare la devi sbloccare la scala
perfetto una ho trovato già un altro
cappello l'ho appena trovato uno fai
vedere cappello lussureggiante Vediamo
se è meglio di quello prima è meglio di
quello di prima ma è bloccato perché
sono è di livello 4 e io sono livello 3
quindi non lo posso ancora usare porco
leoni Vabbè dai sti cazzi Tanto ce l'ho
li posso vendere gli oggetti no Spero no
ecco non ho nuovissimo sono sicuramente
vendere gli oggetti che sono che quelli
li tengo a fare vediamo Salve Cioè non
so se da ogni persona devi vendere
determinati tipo da lui posso vendere
solo tu la mia pergamene lo studente di
Matilda Ti stavo aspettando sono il
calendario della Bottega Thomas Brown dà
un'occhiata a quello che ho Che ne dici
dai Alla fine devo solo comprare le cose
per la prof però vedi che mi dà un
equilibrio
perfetto perfetto
guanti di pelle nera e mi danno neanche
tanto in realtà ma queste sono cose che
ho equipaggiato non ha senso dovrei
venderti questo che ti ho preso a te di
sopra Tra l'altro fa molto ridere non lo
vendo non lo vendo Anzi vendo questo
vendo già la coppola scura È un piacere
fare affari vendo già la coppola scura
perché tanto tra un po' Mi sblocco
subito
Mi sblocco subito il livello successivo
E indosso quello nuovo quindi non ha
senso avere la tenga non credo di fare
combattimenti nel mentre che mi possa
servire come ho detto sta cosa 200
persone
ci siamo dov'è Come si chiama Natti
guainati
Dov'è minchia sei finita in piazza Eh va
bene io qua non ho capito perché non mi
ha fatto comprare robe ma sicuramente
c'è un modo ma vabbè poi più avanti vedo
my friend
ho capito che cosa intendevi quando
dicevi di non sapere qual è il tuo
negozio preferito
seggiamo ancora un po'
se oggi è il giorno in cui riuscirò a
scegliere ma in realtà
ho detto raga l'ho tolto il CAP Non ho
il cappello se devo sbattere datemi con
qualcuno ha perso porca [__] Eh vabbè
Minchia raga ho appena tolto il cappello
mi prende per il culo
Madonna
un troll è un troll di caverna
Vabbè tanto siamo reparo nel caso eh
ma poi a caso ce n'è un altro la Madonna
Buongiorno e mi sa che questo lo devo
sfidare Oddio schiva
possiamo provare con le magie
non mi ricordo ragazzi
e vabbè posso usare un nebbioso
Stai calmo
Grazie
Aspetta che provo
tempo ho fatto proteco e non è servito a
niente
Aspetta che non mi ricordo più taglia
Porco demonio E vabbè lancio magia
Antica
Ma io posso lanciare magia anticamente
piove Minchia ragazzi è fortissima
Scusatemi allora
proteco funziona o no porco del demonio
morto
protego usalo non funziona protego
protego Funziona solo contro
l'incantesimo Quindi se mi caricano devo
solo schivare va bene
Spero che dopo
arresto momento non funziona una sega
Madonna Nati fai schifo Che palle
secondo che io sia più forte
effettivamente però Ah anche se si
scontrato vai vai vai vai vai vai vai
brava
ma Scusatemi ma arresto momento non sai
Scusate posso prendere cose sbagliate la
borsa però se non l'hai ancora fatta e
gli leva anche un botto domande domande
al volo ragazzi Mi serve capire da voi
arresto momento non serve per fermare
una caduta
oppure serve anche per rallentare la
gente io pensavo il servizio solo per
Porca vacca per le cadute Quindi quando
uno cade si arresta invece non serve
proprio anche per rallentare la gente
magia antica
Quindi io posso la Madonna
bellissima
Mamma mia Vai reparto ghiaccio
un attimo che sto lavorando
a posto e mi dai due punti esperienza
che almeno indosso il cappello
Che palle di qua
qua dentro
no però il complesso tratto di riso Ah
sì forse sì
sono lontano sono entrato dal retro
Salve mi scusi e ho visto una volta
fammi vedere se riesco prima
vado a rubargli qualcosa e poi arrivo
ragazzi
ma non è un oggetto Ma che è sto ci sono
fuori Ah no minchia
ma mi spiegate cosa come dovrei fare per
prendere quella roba lì devo avere
veramente una pozione invisibile Vabbè
forziere 49 Ok
ti ruba la tazzina Dimmi
Buongiorno Non credo che ci conosciamo
Permettimi di presentarmi
commerciante di capi straordinari
[Musica]
e per aver riportato la pace prego
un abito gratis
bellissimo
leggendario livello 3 non so quanto sia
utile in realtà Però vabbè ma quanto
costa sta roba per curiosità Vabbè
comunque abito scolastico tradizionale
che ok
nessun cliente esce da stretching
chiamate equipaggiamenti Sì sì lo so
come farlo cioè mi sono già equipaggiato
di roba eh non è la prima volta
attenzione mantelli qua mantelli abiti
Cioè questo faceva schifo non aveva
niente in difesa nulla di nulla la
nostra promessa Anzi Fammelo vendere
faceva cagare quello di prima
hanno me lo fa vendere per quelli Prima
faceva talmente schifo che non faceva
non lo fa vendere non costa non costano
molti vestiti Eh pensavo peggio grazie
dottore
a questo punto direi che ci meritiamo
una bella burrobirra soprattutto tu Sono
burro
ma mi sembra una buona idea ottimo da
questa parte allora
si esce bello anche altri oggetti utili
in combattimento Qualora non mi
interessa però grazie di avermelo detto
ciao ciao
Cos'è sta roba
bellissimo Ma ragazzi puoi fare Ci sono
puoi usare tutti gli oggetti sta roba
Non ha senso Incredibile No io Amo sto
gioco
ragazzina non è assolutamente no
la birra Dammi un po' di burro o birra è
per quello che ho questo gioco che è
successo
filmato
un altro troll
chi è
così pediniamo gente senza motivo
che ti serviva solo un buon diversivo ed
è quello che ti ha mai stato lui è stato
sbaragliato con facilità
[Musica]
Ricordati bene se non arrivi al
bersaglio Non hai alcun valore per me
andiamo
ci hanno visti non credo proprio che
faceva quel Goblin con Victor rookwood
il Goblin della Gazzetta del Profeta
sapevo di averlo già visto
forza infiliamoci nei tre manici veloce
Beh comunque avere il mantello
dell'invisibilità in questi casi sarebbe
utile però
È stato bello rivederti loggook Se sento
qualcosa ti aggiorno Grazie
Madonna Non pensavo fosse così vuoti tra
i manici di scopa è vuoto
abbiamo una faccia nuova
è la prima volta che vengo Benvenuto
Oggi abbiamo la faccia nuova e si gira
con questi occhiali terribili terribili
passerò a vedere come stanno gli altri
residenti e bottegai sono felice che
siate indenni Ciao offrite la burrobirra
che già sto lì
Ma davvero Complimenti
con cui abbiamo a che fare di solito
Ecco appunto
era lovegoc quello che se n'è andato
La tua clientela è peggiorata sirona Sta
tranquillo Victor appena voi due ve ne
andrete la qualità della mia cliente è
la migliorerà parecchio
non disturbare se sta solo bevendo una
burrobirra una parola e vado Forse non
mi hai sentito
ho detto di non disturbare
pare che non vi sia bastato tutto il
sangue versato oggi
vieni Teofilo
i tre manici di scopa non è più lo
stesso non merita i nostri soldi
non berrai burrobirra per sempre
tutto questo con gli occhiali lo so tu
abbia uno spiacevole nemico stai in
guardia procura peggio di qualsiasi
trolley infuriato più o meno il trolley
era veramente pesi zio
prometto di raccontarti tutto ma forse è
meglio rimandare per adesso
bene È arrivato il momento di tornare
sarebbe molto divertente posso rubare
della roba tipo del cibo a questo
vecchio Grazie
forzieri forzieri forzieri i soldi soldi
soldi
forzieri i soldi forzieri forzieri soldi
soldi forzieri cassa da svaligiare con
la solitudine no c'è il piano di sopra i
tre manici di scopa quindi Andrea contro
un attimino
ok
soldi Ah no sciarpa del nome del deserto
forzieri soldi Nice e anche piano di
sopra
quanto cazzo è grosso sto posto raga
quanto Quanto grosso le tre manici di
scopa ci credibile poi guarda che non è
neanche scontato c'è ognuno ogni stanza
la tua Ah perché si può si può entrare
anche dal da questa parte qua perché
sono gli ha fatto strane hai fatto su
una collina Quindi c'è il piano terra
non si capisce qual è il piano terra
piuttosto punto serratura sbloccare
figurati
Dai usciamo
e mi si è sbloccato il Mana in basso a
destra cos'è quella roba là sono pozioni
praticamente
non ho capito Vabbè 'sti cazzi Ah sta
facendo buio eh torni Io tornerei già
che fa buio Dimmi che posso esplorare
Hogwarts Di notte che la cosa che mi
interessa si può ti seguo zia eh Vai vai
Per fortuna c'era sirena già non si
lascia intimorire da fursanti come rukku
dearlo voglio capire cosa sta succedendo
e spero che me lo dirai ma per il
momento credo sia meglio tornare al
castello la professoressa Weasley verrà
presto a sapere dei Troll posto che non
lo sappia già non voglio farla
preoccupare
la notte nella sala comune vai alla
mappa
Ah posso viaggiare velocemente
Giustamente sì sì sì
ok Vai verso la zona comune la mia sala
comune qua
sì eccolo qua
via Polvere volante ragazzi e Vamos
Ma vista la polvere volante manca per
viaggiare ancora velocemente manca la
scopa non vedo l'ora di prendere anche
quella le due cose sono alohomora e la
scopa perché veramente quella Però io
vorrei anche visitare il castello di
notte non posso andare a dormire e basta
Salve
o peggio gufo Ah sono a livello 4 bene
perché andando a dormire sali di livello
Ok allora metto subito un cappello
quello fatto bene che è
questo
bello esteticamente È proprio figo
Complimenti
proprio un bel cappello Eh beh il
cappello
io utilizzerei il cappello
faceva veramente ridicola Vai cappello
ridicola a parte è stato figo vamos
piano di sottos no dove devo andare ha
ricevuto la posta via gufo
bene
Ah professor fig Vieni dal mio ufficio
Ho scoperto qualcosa sul medaglione
trovato alla Gringo va bene andiamo la
stanza del professor Pig che sta a me
l'hanno già sbloccata
quindi posso andarci direttamente con la
polvere vediamo
e qua Però l'avevo già sbloccata basta
fare così
Ormai ho capito come funziona ragazzi
ormai ormai
vero mago di Hogwarts vero studente di
Hogwarts Eccoci qua allora
di qua
se mi servono al piano di sotto eh Porco
demonio
no fatti i cazzi tuoi
no Avada Kedavra qua Ok Eccoci
questa Laura del professor figo quella
del video precedente
c'è qualcosa che posso rubare pure a lui
Yes
chi
celestiale grigio chiaro cos'è che ha
rubato
il professor Fi quello che io prendo la
lui non è rubare perché siamo
alleati nel combattere le forze del male
quindi non è rubare è tutto di
guadagnato questo film come se la mia
agenda non fosse già abbastanza piena al
Ministero mi ha incaricato di
organizzare alquanto Sicuramente arrivo
il nuovo studente Hogwarts del quinto
anno per giunta Ah quasi scopre che in
realtà mi odia la professoressa che sarà
necessario nominare qualcuno mi faccia
l'accompagnatore e mentore
assegno a lei questo compito La prego di
Recarsi alla professoressa Weasley per
tutti i dettagli del caso professor
finas nigerius Black
bene signori sopra Let's go fratello
Dov'è dottore
ogni volta quanti oggetti tu puoi fare
in una quanto ci hanno messo a fare sto
gioco quanti oggetti quanta roba quanta
roba quanta troppa forziere 43 galeoni
rubati vai
non si ripara questo va bene allora
facciamo finta di niente
ho rotto un vaso e ho rubato dei soldi
perfetto che è successo
cosa è successo
Mi sono steso per terra ed è spawnato il
prof Vabbè professore' sono felice di
vederla lo stesso vale per me per
fortuna stai bene Ho udito dell'attacco
Troll a oggs erano corazzati le armature
emanavano un bagliore oscuro come il
collare del drago argento Goblin Run
Rock lo ha usato per controllare il
drago Ma come e perché lo fanno perché
vogliono prendermi a calcinair
parlare con Victor rockfood era a oxmidt
erano un diversivo ideato da Run Rock
affinché rookewood potesse catturarmi e
ci sarebbe riuscito se sirona i clienti
dei tre manici di scopa non fossero
intervenuti una notizia pessima questa
evidentemente i Goblin di raro che i
maghi oscuri vogliono ciò che abbiamo
trovato in quella camera blinda ma ormai
ho scoperto un'iscrizione quando l'ho
letta ad alta voce è apparsa questa
mappa ingegno cos'è È indubbia la mappa
e la mappa del malandrino
però conduce alla biblioteca al reparto
proibito per la precisione e anche un
po' oltre vedo tracce di magia lì
bellissima
Anch'io non vedo l'ora di scoprire cosa
si cela la mia giornata
per non parlare di ciò che è accaduto a
Miriam mi ha insegnato qualcosa è che ci
troviamo su un sentiero irto di pericoli
vorrei ti esercitarsi un po' con la tua
presenza prima di proseguire
la biblioteca magari cerchiamo solo un
libro Sì forse ma dobbiamo essere pronti
migliorato le tue abilità difensive va
bene Grazie prof
del tuo arrivo Beh devo andare ad
allenarmi con le magie poi mi fa fare
sta cosa Che palle Volevo andare subito
Vabbè nel prossimo episodio
eh Però di notte si va nel porto i primi
video ragazzi cioè di notte perché c'è
un sacco di
è suggestivo molto più suggestivo dove
devo andare
Boh Non ho capito
se vuoi i punti perché non vedo il
segnalino
di sotto di sopra di sotto
Non ho capito dove io stia andando ma
vabbè sti cazzi Allora ok
Io vorrei saltarmi tutta la scuola però
non si può usare la scopa dentro peccato
hanno fatto solo fare de George
[Musica]
che ha urlato
ti aiuterei io però ho paura che mi
darai un compito di due ore e mezza
Quindi non lo faccio
Salve prof mi devi insegnare a fare la
vado a Kedavra perché sennò non mi fanno
sono qui per il nuovo incantesimo che
voleva insegnarmi i professionisti
il professor fig ha detto che devi
completare tutti gli incarichi di magia
difensiva con una certa urgenza di
conseguenza Devi imparare
L'incantesimo del Fuoco veramente è
utile per accendere torcia bruciare
ragnatele incendio Se necessario
assolutamente sì ma prima di iniziare
vorrei che portassi a Termini alcuni
incarichi alcuni ti potrebbero
sorprendere spesso gli studenti
sottovalutano le conoscenze dei loro
professori torna da me quando avrai
finito e inizieremo a lavorare su in
cielo
che devo raccoglierti scarpe
Vinci due round i pacchetti incrociati
Ma che ti incrociate sarebbe un duello
clandestino ad Hogwarts però non penso
mi mandi la prof a fare sta roba in
carriera professoressa
Sì mi ha fatto fare mi ha fatto fare
bacchette incrociate alla professoressa
cioè sono scontri clandestini Beh
Brother l'avevo fatta già sta cosa nella
chiederti di un club Sebastiano
[Musica]
Ok l'ultima volta non sapevo usare gli
incantesimi adesso non so sempre usare
gli incantesimi però
teoricamente
Ok perfetto
Beh è una merda
e non funziona niente
Però hanno usato anche su di melving
garmiuser bravissimo bravissimo così
funziona Ok uno è andato l'altro devo
solo picchiarli i barili in faccia
Beh dai è andata meglio della prima
visto che sodollare un po' di più ancora
devo capire come fare protego comunque
perché lo faccio sempre i momenti
sbagliati È un po' come il Perry in Dark
Souls Sebastian non si sbagliava su di
te la competizione sarà ardua ma
continua era diverso
fantastico
è conclusa puoi accedere al manico un
ottimo modo per Diventare esperti di
combinazioni magiche se vieni te lo
faccio vedere
Spero di rivederti presto e il manichino
è questo qua
questo qua Forse con
Action ma con Wingardium
la pagina della guida pratica Ok
fin qua è tutto a posto devo riparlare
con lui devo rifare bacchette incrociate
no sì Ciao Luca Il prossimo round di
bacchetta in croce Ma me lo fa rifare
sono pronto sono un altro duello
al partner del duello
va bene ma devo farlo di nuovo per la
professoressa questo non so
sì certo non vedo l'ora
Ti chiedo scusa in anticipo a tre contro
due facciamo
no tre contro due Sì tre contro due
vabbè
Chi fra gli iscritti di Viola quelli che
energici come l'incantesimo di appello
Accio Accio Accio per infrangere un uno
scudo
e Sparami cazzo Piquadro mi proteggono
non succede niente quando non mi
proteggo mi sparate in 26
Ciao ciao
merda merda mi ha colpito
eh ho sbagliato mano
[Musica]
merda sarò sempre quando non devo
pararmi ho sbagliato non mi sono
liberato dalle
Raga non ha tanta vita
Sparagli questo prima che ecco
via questo Vabbè anche con le cose
lanciate Comunque infrangoli così Viola
eh Minchia Porco demonio tutto è ancora
viva
Dai non è andato malissimo che non so
ancora pararmi per bene quella cosa
Ancora devo capirla
Beh tre contro due ragazzi Comunque non
male eh grazie grazie
ma dopo quest'ultimo round vogliono
davvero farti fuori tutti va bene se
spari di vincere il prossimo round O
almeno sopravvivere continua ad
allenarti senza sosta Ti farò sapere
appena saremo pronti a presto
arrivederci
no ben capito è
continuo bello va che ti incrociate
Comunque
vado c'è il ponte Raga ma sto male
Ma dove siamo qua allora non me la
ricordavo bene sta zona Beh Bello
bellissimo
si può inquadrare anche da fuori sì
Peccato che peccato che non c'è la
modalità fotografia perché qua mica ci
starebbe benissimo
ma tra l'altro questo lo avevo anche già
scoperto come ho fatto non mi ricordo
come faccio a Non ricordarmelo Come dico
sempre
possibile cioè perché l'avevo già
scoperto non ci sono mai stato qua
allora se vai qua giù in teoria ci
dovrebbe essere la capanna lì a Grid
Eccola
mais hanno riprodotto uguale a Hogwarts
ragazzi l'unica roba è che non ho capito
perché mi ha sbloccato quella polvere
volante lì non non c'ero mai stato là
posso entrare qua dentro
lo posso
[Musica]
cos'è che c'è
forziere
occhiali in legno Ah Quando una roba fa
più schifo te lo dice direttamente Vabbè
tanto tutta roba che si vende Quindi va
bene
è una porta qua che era sul Madonna che
bello Raga io sto per rivelarsi
pericoloso se non faccio attenzione
Ma stai zitto che sei un mago tu sei un
mago Lore Lorenzo bene Allora
vediamoci dalle palle questo sti cosi
aspetta che prendo un po' di mosche così
è bellissimo Guarda che posto
incredibile
cazzo
bene No ho preso un po' di roba perché
se faccio solo le missioni e basta Poi
rimango senza niente le cose questo
posso colpire
mucca
Vai Ho colpito una mucca senza un motivo
e qualcosa che c'è
questo è un segreto secondo me non so
cosa sia
ok
e questo è c'è una tipa Salve giorno
sono qua solo per rubare
tutto il resto del gioco no
[Musica]
cappotto araldico Minchia leggendario
Raga ho trovato un leggendario sto male
ma ecco la roba che non ho capito ma qua
quando tu trovi un qualcosa cioè un
altro che gioca che apre quel forziere
trova proprio quella cosa o randomico lo
Spondi oggetti E questo proprio non l'ho
capita Vabbè sfiga prendi questo
Ok abito del giardino
Lower of
bellissima va bene
Fammi provare a vedere
[Musica]
le cose che non mi servono tipo a te
Salve signore Salve Io posso vendere la
sua mercanzia vai Che cosa c'è in
vendita
Con cosa posso aiutarti
Ah no lui ha le mosche Ok se no ti vende
le pozioni di generatrici che prenderò
ragazzi perché non ne ho veramente
segnato e vendiamo Ehm tutto tranne alla
due sciarpe ciò sciarpa comune fa schifo
Non avrò più difficoltà
Grazie gli occhiali tondi fanno schifo
occhiali in legno e oro fanno più schifo
dei miei non è vero però
Allora vendo tutte le cose inutili ok E
questo lo vendo
però non mi dà niente quindi non lo
vendo Allora vendo quest'altro e vendo
quest'altro tanto ho trovato leggendario
che si vende a 200 leggendario
va bene grazie dottore spero Io no
Arrivederci Allora vediamo se riesco a
farmelo se me lo fa più equipaggiare già
penso di sì
ok ok per il viso c'ho altri occhiali
che però fanno schifo
occhiali in legno perché fanno più
schifo Fanno più schifo dei miei
stranissimo
[Musica]
questo qua
Bello è anche molto più bellissimo
ragazzi bellissimo c'è il simbolo di
Grifondoro dietro e vabbè Quello è un
altro discorso però
e a questo ci ha più attacco però Quindi
mettiamo questo e il resto lo vendo
facciamo così
TAC e il resto lo vendiamo perché se no
è molto meglio così
c'è un oggetto di maggior rarità sia più
potente Beh perché conta anche il
livello ovviamente quindi vendiamo anche
quello di rarità Con cosa posso aiutarti
oggi
ma tutta sta roba è tutta roba che
questo questo equipaggiamento qui è
quello che non ho quindi posso vendere
tutto
o no Sì sì questo è tutta roba che non
ho addosso Quindi vendiamola se non me
ne faccio niente
mi sono fatto un po' di soldini eh Raga
non male Oddio ho sbagliato Vabbè bene
soldi robe forzieri un vortice Marrone
una pergamena
Allora sono rimasto che dovevo andare No
Apri Hogwarts
devo andare qui carico la professoressa
va bene
Eh però Fammici andare no Porco demonio
le selezionate la missione allenamento e
caricare
Scusatemi raga quei comandi sono ancora
arrugginitissimo perché non li so
ma Hogwarts
Boh
Fammi andare qua
Allora ragazzi nel prossimo episodio
Penso che andremo nel reparto proibito
perché
succederanno le cose peggiori del mondo
visto che il reparto proibito è proibito
Appunto quindi
ci vediamo il prossimo episodio
iscrivetevi al canale lasciate un bel mi
piace e fatemi sapere se Madonna Guarda
che bella stato unica sono proprio
incredibile
Ci vediamo al prossimo video di Hogwarts
Legacy Eh beh ragazzi